what's going on guys today we're going
to be breaking down the spoilers for my
academia chapter 325 in which we finally
got updates on characters we've not
heard from for a long time including
kirigiri izawa and all might although to
be fair the all my appearance was pretty
brief the name of this chapter is
connected by one for all and in it the
standoff between class 1a and the
civilians come to an end with the focus
now gradually shifting to toga possibly
infiltrating ua
before we get into it don't forget to
sub with notifications on for weekly
breakdowns like this and as always let
me know in the comments what you think
of the spoilers
okay so the chapter picks up where we
left off last week with kota and the
giant girl running towards deku and here
it says that the very first panel is one
of kota's sneakers mineta also tries to
run towards deku because as we know he's
in love with him but either stops him
saying that this is not their turn kota
then calls deku midoriya nichan and i
didn't know what this was but i googled
it here and it says that essentially it
means older brother like it's a nice way
of referring to your older brother so
basically what he's saying is big
bromidoria he apologizes for being
paralyzed with fear because in the last
few chapters he was really afraid to do
anything because he's a young kid but as
we saw in the last chapter you know he
finally got that courage and ran towards
deku he states that he felt inspired
when he saw the giant woman talking
about how uzuku protected her and he
goes on to say that everything will be
alright so deku can stop crying the
giant woman also cries saying that many
shelters rejected her because of her
quirk she says that she was very lucky
to find deku and thanks him calling him
mr crybaby hero which is the same name
that many of deku's real-life haters
give him but i guess she means it in a
nice way the two of them then give deku
a hug and the old man from the first
chapter starts defending midoriya saying
that the other civilians are too
hysterical and that obviously deku
doesn't want to stay there resting
forever the old man continues stating
that because they are spectators the
civilians have gotten used to seeing all
might fighting and have forgotten that
heroes have a heart he says that after
the war many heroes gave up so those
that are left must have an unwavering
determination he ends his speech by
asking how long are we planning to stay
as mere spectators now what he said
about all might is so valid because
because all this time all might was
saving people with a smile on his face
and he never ever showed that he was
afraid you know there was every scenario
where all might actually uh was
vulnerable until camino so i think that
you know people still have to get used
to the idea of heroes being actually
human beings rather than these uh
invincible monsters that that they were
perceived as because of all might um and
yeah i think it's a valid statement the
civilian who opposed deku in the last
chapter says that some people were
calling him all for one's henchmen while
others were calling him the hero's
greatest weapon and he was confused by
those conflicting opinions he asks deku
if after resting at ue if he will be
able to return things back to normal and
decker replies saying that they will all
fight for it ectoplasm then goes outside
the ua barrier to meet endeavour hawks
and shoto who were just standing there
and i didn't mention this in my last
chapter review but endeavour's outfit
right now i don't know what he's trying
to do right now i guess he's trying to
be undercover or something but it looks
like he's a buff detective or something
like that but anyway ectoplasm asks them
if they heard of shaco's speech and
tells them that they need to come in
because they won't want to miss what's
happening in this moment endeavor is
blaming himself saying that he just made
deku wander around with no progress
horse corrects him saying that the
progress is right in front of their eyes
and that one flaw is a power formed by
the connection between people it's
because of one for all that all might
connected with midoriya midoriya
connected with class 1a and uraraka
connected the civilians to izuku what
comes next is a beautiful double spread
of the civilians handing out umbrellas
to the students because it is raining
and hawks is saying that if from now on
each person starts thinking about the
whole a society where heroes have all
the time in the world will surely arise
after this todoroki reminds his dad that
they need to stop toya together and
endeavour agrees
moving on nezu is on the phone with
izawa and he says that class will name
was able to do what nezu himself
couldn't and azawa asked him to tell eda
that he did a great job nezu arts izawa
about his leg which was cut off during
the war arc and azalea says that he
hasn't gotten used to it as much as
mirko we then see a panel of his
prosthetic leg on top of that although
these leaks don't say it aizawa also has
an eye patch because he lost his right
eye meaning that you know comparing to
the start of the series aizawa has been
severely nerfed i mean after the usj
attack he wasn't able to use a ratio for
the same amount of time as before and
now in the present day he's essentially
lost half his quirk so he's just never
going to be as effective as he once was
anyway it's stated that kirigiri is
being kept in the central hospital and
doctors are trying to get him to talk
but according to aizawa there has been
no progress yet
what makes this interesting is the fact
that kurugiri is still in the hero's
possession because he would assume that
during the prison break all for one
would specifically try to get that guy
but somehow the heroes did manage to
keep a hold of him i guess off one just
didn't know where he was in the prison
and i guess if kirikou has been sedated
then he wouldn't have made an escape for
it unlike the other villains nedu says
that even if it's small there is still a
spark of hope and you know with erie
being a thing i've always maintained
that erie can you know reverse shurikumo
back into his original form the only
problem is that she needs to accumulate
enough energy to rewind him back and
currently at the moment we still don't
know what she needs to accumulate for a
quirk to work but besides that i do
think it's possible that the real
shurikuma will return
izawa then says that the search for toga
continues and that they have discovered
her maximum transformation time as a
countermeasure they make all refugees go
through a period of isolation before
they enter ua to ensure that she will
not infiltrate aizawa says that ua is
their fortress and that now is the time
for revenge the last panel of the
chapter shows all might standing near
the ua barrier with a worried face and
yeah that's the end of the chapter so
the last time we saw all might he was
you know deku would run away all might
was alone by himself and staying was
just around the corner now between that
moment and this moment we have no idea
what happened to all might like we have
no idea if he was attacked if he spoke
to stay normally like we just have no
idea the only thing we do know is that
he has a worried face looking at the ua
barrier so the question then becomes why
would he be worried what would all might
have to be worried about going back to
ua the crackpot theory is that this
isn't really all mine and that it's toga
and i'll explain why that's possible we
all know that toga is a massive fan of
stain in fact stain was the reason why
she joined the league of villains in the
first place pretty much so now that toga
is on the loose now that stain is also
on the loose it's possible that she
actively searched for him found him and
now these two are working together now
obviously that is a stretch but if she
is working with stain then it's very
possible that this all might who is you
know worried outside the ue barrier that
all my is toga and she was trying to
infiltrate and now she's a bit worried
because she's not sure if she's gonna
actually be able to do it because of the
ua barrier i mean that's just a crackpot
theory let me know what you think in the
comments but it's possible i think it's
possible
anyway guys thank you for watching the
video and if you haven't already then be
sure to hit that sub button as we are on
the long road to 400k by the end of the
year hopefully we can do it but i would
really appreciate your support until the
next one peace out